kevin hall talked to all that [ __ ] fake  gangster you're not touching he's from  chechnya touch gloves you can't touch  gloves  he didn't touch gloves no there's no  touching he's from chechnya  they don't touch gloves buddy no he's  going to talk all that [ __ ] and then  apparently got  spartan kicked backstage i mean you  think this guy's going to touch gloves  again if there was that an animosity if  a  if another grown man kicked me in the  [ __ ] middle of my chest in front of  everybody and then they held me back and  it was chaos and people were throwing  [ __ ]  you think they're touching again this  adds to it  you think they're gonna you would never  be like dude all good bro let's get it  what yeah  bro you kicked me in my chest yesterday  and now i can do something about it for  25 minutes i'm not touching your glove  we're not touching gloves